it's the fear of raising the price that
kills solo entrepreneurs I run a Yoga
Center a block from here yes and I do
everything literally everything of
course any advice is it bothering you
right now
can you afford to hire an entry-level
employee to do the shift that you most
hate doing no but I could work on making
more money can you charge more for your
service yeah absolutely I know you can
by you having the courage and changing
the price from 80 an hour to 120 you
could then hire that person to do the
things that you don't want to do which
immediately makes it more sustainable
it's the fear of raising the price that
kills solo entrepreneurs and her
competitors are not real competitors
even because you're uniquely you and
whoever likes doing it with you likes
doing it with you that's true there is
no competitor we have the juice
the competitor is your head
telling you that's not true like I
can't who am I to raise it 20 bucks that
person I think is doing a good job is
ten dollars less that's who's picking
you up that's your competitor